hello I'm Alistair Murray I'm the water
manager for the Invercargill City
Council people on rainwater collection
or their own supply would not have to
carry any cost relating to the
alternative water supply or any cost
associated with water supply the
protection need that we require which
could be for a drought that lasts for a
period of time several days or weeks or
contamination on-site storage is not
likely to be sufficient to protect us
against that desalination is possible at
the RET beach but it's a very costly
option both in capital and operating
costs yes at some times of emergencies
drought as one of these contamination of
the Eureka River could be another well I
believe them that may assist the river
system of some degree it's a little bit
outside what we're talking about here
which is to have an alternative water
supply to act in times of emergency
yes I suppose a lot of people think that
that might be a solution but really we
need a lot of water even to act for an
emergency if we have the Arita system
knocked out for a number of days we need
a lot of water this exists of those
would be governed by how long a drought
or emergency event lasted for if the
event lasts long time will run out so
we're back to square one
whereas underground water supplies have
a almost immeasurable amount of water
underneath the ground so that's what
we're aiming for at this stage well I
can say that fluoridation is quite a
contentious issue the council has
decided to continue fluoridation but as
monitoring the situation year by year
legislation has changed a little bit and
so much that now we are to be guided by
the local area Health Board and to date
we received no advice that fluoridation
is harmful so we continue to fluoridate
a yes we could have and we can do it now
but it is a very costly exercise people
don't realize just how close we were to
a very sticky situation with last
summer's drought in January we're only
seven days away from getting to the
limit of our water permit to take water
from Eureka River we do need a water
supply as a community to be there a
reliable water supply so we do need to
concentrate on looking and giving a
second string to air bow to spread our
risk
you